build it draw it flight Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is
new build all like is a polish-born yarn
artist living in New York City that
creates massive crocheted installations
like covering this train it took two
days and four assistants to complete and
is on display in which Poland she's done
several great installations with yarn
including the end is far the animal ball
and the crocheted rickshaw sunset
skateboard company makes LED lighted
boards that lasts up to 100,000 hours no
batteries are required because the
lights are powered by the motion of the
wheels they give you the option to pick
one of their designs like the ghost or
the wave or you could just build your
own artist Brian Detmer made these
awesome skeleton sculptures from melted
cassette tapes including a bird elk and
bull skulls
he also made these human skulls named
after the tapes he used to make them
such as 80s metal and women of pop his
many more amazing sculptures so be sure
to check out his website for more the
arch of birdcage table was created by
French designer grégoire de la Forest
and the main part of the cage is
attached underneath the table and clear
viewing tubes protrude through the top
giving the birds the ability to fly up
into them and become part of the
tabletop decoration draw dirty little
secrets it's an art series by Sarah
Rossano using dirt from local parks as a
medium some of her dirty little secrets
include lonely panda ants New York
skyline and a cat coiffure LED bird is a
photo series by photographer Rene Esmond
using both a hairstylist and an art
director the series includes an owl crow
and a falcon and now for the Pink's a
masculine figures in pink series done by
Scott Sheldon
1,000 channels is an ongoing street art
series by artist Herbert Baglioni and
this said he used an abandoned
psychiatric hospital in Italy to
showcase some of his haunting silhouette
paintings client Alfie producer plays 42
current pop songs arranged himself in a
row in one take without any editing
impression Rhapsody is Paula houses
version of Bohemian Rhapsody done in a
plethora of famous voices will not let
you go Madame Gold is spill la will not
let you go let him go will not let you
go the fantastic cdza does justin genre
lake which is a cover of justin
timberlake's my love in 13 different
genres
finally here's Vivaldi tribute played by
fourteen-year-old Tina and it is awesome
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bidipi an entire video dedicated to
your creations and as always thanks for
watching